-It is time for
"Tonight Show Hashtags"!
-♪ Hashtags ♪
♪ Hashtags ♪
-Oh, we do this thing every week
where I send out a hashtag
and ask you guys to
respond to that topic.
Since it looks like
the president will be
moving out of
The White House soon,
I sent out a hashtag called
#TimeToMove
and I asked you guys to
tweet something
funny, weird, or embarrassing
about a place you used to live,
something that happened that let
you know it was time to move.
Within minutes,
it was a trending topic,
so thank you for playing along.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And now I thought I'd share some
of my favorite
#TimeToMove responses
from you guys.
This first one is from
@SandieMoore.
She says...
Yeah, time to move.
Everyone needs a hobby.
This one is from @MettaJoelKatz.
He says...
You got to get one of those
Dirt Devils.
Or one of those Dyson jawns.
-I don't know.
The Dyson says
it never loses suction.
-It doesn't.
-But I think it does.
[ Imitates vacuum running ]
Which one was I doing?
Dirt Devil or Dyson?
-I don't know,
'cause your impression sucks.
[ Laughter ]
-What? That makes no sense.
Oh, I got you.
-Yeah, man.
-Oh! Oh.
-Yeah.
I just got it.
Yeah, wow, wow, wow.
Any joke where you have to do
that afterwards...
[ Laughter ]
And hold it?
That was awesome.
This next one is from
@Real Danye West.
Real Danye West.
You get it?
-Not the imposter.
-No. This is Real Danye West.
Oh, yeah. So, he says...
No. This one's from
@knockknock penny.
She says...
♪ What's love ♪
[ Humming ]
Dude, did you say --
Who wrote "Private Dancer"?
You said somebody cool.
-Dude from Dire Straits.
-Mark Knopfler.
-Yeah.
-My mom was into
that whole album,
and then that was the song
that kind of stuck out with her.
And she would do,
like, a good --
She would sing it, but not quite
knowing what it's about.
So we were kids going like,
"That's pretty good.
And, like, this is --
You shouldn't sing
'Private Dancer' to us.
You're saying you're..."
Eh, whatever.
Any old music will do.
This one's from @lex 1110.
He says...
"Bob, Emily,
quick house meeting?
What do you guys think?"
This last one is from
@caitlincarrickm.
She says...
There you go, everybody.
Those are
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of
our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.